welcome back to folding ideas let's talk
about dudes bros dudes homies the fellas
boys or just men guys in modern culture
have an odd relationship this is a big
subject and we have a lot to cover so
we're gonna make a thing out of it
that's right
we're making a thing this is man Mia
movie month so let's get ready we've got
all kinds of man stuff like this
baseball cap and oK we've only got the
baseball cap first up in mmmmmm is a
look at the Tony Danza 1989 classic
she's out of control from the greatest
oldies to the most unforgettable
classics your rock-and-roll memories are
safe with us
97.5 ke h ey fm what you you don't
remember this blockbuster sensation okay
so the film itself is for the most part
an inoffensive and completely
forgettable bit of late 80s southern
california tripe proving that the
independent film community can produce
garbage that is just as cliched and
churned out as any fill-in-the-blanks
comedy Hollywood can come up with hell
pretty much the only reason I even know
about this feature-length sitcom is
because I saw it on sale for $5 at
Safeway that's right
not being sluiced out by a closing
blockbuster not the crap bin at a Best
Buy not even the shady downtown corner
gray market DVD peddler a grocery store
little did I know what I'd actually
acquired this movie is such a mash of
banal recycled ideas that it slips into
the surreal nothing makes sense and
space and time warp and buckle under the
discordant strains of the script at any
moment I was expecting the fabric of
Tony danza's reality to rip open pouring
out a million minions of Dagon and as a
thought come to harvest our thought
needs to power their fear engines sadly
there is no such beautiful
bait-and-switch there's just a really
really lame one so let's dig in
she's out of control isn't about a she
at all the working title of the film was
daddy's little girl but that's not
accurate either it's not about the girl
it's about daddy oh and that's the bait
and switch by the way yeah it's about a
guy in his late 30s really not the teen
daughter the guy nope yep I did the same
thing so this is our main character Doug
Simpson played by Tony Danza this
character is basically a mad lib of
danza's most successful role is tony
Miceli on who's the boss replace
baseball with radio and connecticut with
LA both of them have a case of dead wife
both of their central conflicts revolve
around the women in their lives and both
are an unintentional bastion of impotent
masculinity so the movie opens with Doug
trying to assault Wallace Shawn before
jumping out of the window of the radio
station he manages this is intended to
create mystery and suspense but really
it's just a confusing set up for the
framing device and heartwarming finale
the bulk of the movie is framed as a
flashback as Doug tells his story to the
two least competent police detectives
ever the rest of our major players are
Doug's girlfriend his therapist the
oldest daughter the gay boyfriend the
dangerous boyfriend the rapist and the
youngest daughter the oldest daughter is
dating the gay boyfriend that breaks up
with him on her 15th birthday at a 50s
diner themes disco man cocaine is a hell
of a drug Doug leaves for a conference
the girlfriend gives the oldest daughter
a makeover montage Doug comes home and
flips his lid because in the week since
she was converted into a hottie she's
got every boy in the entire city looking
to bone her okay at this point here when
I was watching for the first time I made
two notes least reliable narrator ever
and I think Doug just lost his mind see
when we first bought the movie here's
what I predicted girl gets a makeover
gets a boyfriend and dad thinks she's on
drugs but it's just a wacky
misunderstanding then she gets into real
trouble dad saves the day and in the end
dad and daughter both learn important
garbage about blah blah blah trust
because blah blah blah forever but dad
DS de blah blah blah lighten up and
daughter needs blah blah blah obey he
needs to relax but ultimately the
parental judgment is vindicated because
Tina
boys are rapists in training so what
happens party makeover boys beach
psychiatrist car psychiatrist proposal
psychiatrist grounded psychiatrist prom
date rape daddy save fight happy ending
it's a sitcom plot that you'd normally
cram into 30 minutes along with a beep
lot about the doofus brother trying to
jump his bike over the swimming pool
this is a feature film though so they
have to pad it out and Pat it they do
how repetition they Pat it by repeating
themselves like they do something then
they do it again in an arbitrary bid at
making the film longer to pad the
runtime padding here's why I thought
Doug had lost his mom
when he finds out that the oldest
daughter has attracted the attention of
every rapist in training in LA he vows
it he'll be a real manly man man and
take control of his household because
he's the dad this is followed by a
montage of rapists being turned away at
the door step after the montage Doug
tosses and turns in bed driven to fever
dreams where he vows total control then
they do the montage again with
completely new rapists that's right a
completely new but functionally
identical montage of junior rapists
lining up to rape daddy's little girl I
was pretty sure the film had lost its
mind at that point I was starting to
really hope that it would continue a
long slow degrading descent into
delirium and madness really break this
character over its knee it goes back to
boring sitcom mode for a bit but I had
really really high hopes for a complete
rail jump when the beach scene came up
there's this moment where Doug is trying
to desperately hold on to his version of
reality where his daughter is just his
child and he's the only man in her life
and then it all comes crashing down as
he realizes that his daughter is
willingly sexualizing herself all the
rapists on the beach are looking at her
and there's nothing he can do about it
everywhere he looks dicks and rapists
honestly this moment is amazing and it's
wasted in this move
see there's a perfect two part break
here like there's the initial moment
where the structural integrity actually
fails he waves her in to shore and then
sees her running her bosom bouncing in
her swimsuit then this happens this face
right here is the moment his reality
actually broke he keeps going but he's a
car with a broken driveshaft all that's
carrying him forward is inertia he tries
to brush it off that snapping sound
wasn't anything serious I just need to
give it a bit more gas then she
challenges his reality after my body
just after my body
I prayed in that moment his mind would
snap completely and he'd be back in Nam
stabbing Charlie for America well he
body assaulted this kid with his own
popsicle stick it would be equal parts
terrible and glorious a legend of cinema
no one would ever forget the Tony Danza
film that started with the Brady Bunch
and ended with Rambo instead it's just
crap there's a chuckle to be had when
his fancy car gets hit by a train and
there's a strange fun to be had when a
young Matthew Perry shows up as an
overachieving date rapist but that's
about it for fun aside from that it's
just a load of subtext of men as
impotent prisoners in their own lives
see there's almost an intelligent point
being made here but it's being made all
wrong and this is a theme that we're
going to explore more in depth over the
rest of the month there's this theme
that Doug is trapped and foiled by the
women in his life kitchen everything was
flying when it was the status quo
everyone was mostly happy and secure
then the man left the women alone and
they went and messed everything up they
messed it up by bringing other men into
the picture and men hate each other
because other mineral thieves liars and
rapists it's boys that are happening to
these girls was just Simpson do you have
any idea how many times the average
teenage boy thinks about sex in a day
see he's not even safe from the men that
he chooses to interact with his bosses
threatened his job security his
psychiatrist dispenses faulty advice and
the happy ending includes a bit worse
Doug agrees to
verbally fight his psychiatrist every
week on the radio for public
entertainment I know that a lot of this
isn't new observations about culture and
themes there's a lot of discussion out
there about the male gaze and what it
means for culture but honestly most of
the discussion I see is talking about
the impact on the female and queer
population don't get me wrong that's
very very important but let's take
another look at this for a second what
is a man in a movie angry defensive bad
at communication helpless ignorant
incompetent better off when he listens
to his own instincts prey to larger
predators control secure its boys that
are happening to these girls
we're also saddling Jana with a built-in
family you really think that fair you
teasing little [ __ ] I've got five boys
thank God this depiction of men is
helpless slaves of their base desires
still operating off of caveman logic
yeah that's all part of male gaze and
you know what that's an almost
terrifying amount of inward aggression
and self-loathing so you know what guys
I think we need to have a chat